alors en rester là il ya un débat
politique le gps est beaucoup plus
précis que le bluetooth en matière de
tracking mais le gouvernement ne veut
pas utiliser le gps et préfère utiliser
le bluetooth donc on accepte d'avoir de
l'à-peu-près pour respecter davantage de
liberté parce que l'utilisation du gps
de téléphone est jugé comme trop
imprudentes russie fpt
donc non ce n'est pas que la technologie
et et de l'à peu près c'est que le
gouvernement ne veut pas utiliser la
technologie la plus efficace qui pose un
libertin problème de liberté
individuelle
c'est vrai que si on utilisait le gps on
connaîtrait nos deux déplacements on
sort est précisément où nous avons des
épées et où nous sommes alors que en
utilisant le bluetooth on sait
simplement que notre téléphone a été en
contact bluetooth avec un autre
téléphone et que en plus on n'a même pas
neutre non ces jeunes simplement des
chiffres qui nous permettent de
retrouver l'autre téléphone et de lui
envoyer un message sans même qu'on sache
en tout cas le serveur central n'est pas
censé savoir à qui il s'adresse
toute façon si le gouvernement accepte
une méthode de tracking qui marche pas
très bien et qu'elle ne soit pas
indispensable
c'est parce que la mortalité du virus
est faible la mortalité du virus est
autour de 0,5 pour cent maximum si ce
virus tué 30 40 50 70% des gens infectés
on imposerait un système non plus par
bluetooth mais par gps et on aurait un
tracking et un flicage extrêmement
autoritaire
donc le débat sur le tracking il est ici
traduit uniquement le fait que la
mortalité de ce virus est faible
je vous assure que si elle était forte
on aurait des mesures extrêmement
coercitif parce que aucun homme
politique n'accepte rai qu'il y ait 20
30 40 millions de morts en france
[Musique]